[Music]
from the Royal privacy of Buckingham
Palace where the Queen's coffin had
remained overnight
[Music]
through gilded Gates on the back of a
gun Carriage onto the streets of the
British capital
the coffin draped in the Royal Standard
the Imperial Crown resting on top
the king and Princess William and Harry
walked slowly behind joined by the
Queen's other children and Senior staff
from the Royal households
tens of thousands of people line The
Roots synonymous with State visits Royal
weddings and decades ago Queen
Elizabeth's own coronation
for the vast majority of mourners here
Queen Elizabeth is the only monarch they
have ever known the end of the second
Elizabethan age is slowly marching to a
close this the long goodbye to one of
the last icons of the 20th century
down the mile across horse guards parade
ground where the queen has for so many
years come to inspect her troops
and then along Whitehall past government
departments and Downing Street to the
houses of Parliament and the 900 year
old Westminster Hall
the Archbishop of Canterbury Justin
Welby conducting prayers after the
coffin's arrival
with thy servant Queen Elizabeth
and all the faithful Departed
her own mother Lane stayed here 20 years
ago
and now Queen Elizabeth's coffin resting
on a raised Podium a cataphale where it
will remain until her State funeral on
Monday
the doors of the Great Hall are opened
24 hours a day to allow a continuous
queue of mourner's kilometers long to
file silently past
senior Royals too are expected to pay
their own tribute standing guard by the
coffin in a tradition known as the vigil
of the princes
Nev Barker Al Jazeera London